uh one of the real questions
that we are going to answer merely by
observing
the american political landscape for the
next i think in the next few months it
will become clear
is whether the sparks
of a republican civil war that we saw
two months ago
will turn into a fire and there are sort
of two possible paths
forward uh it's conceivable that
right-wing media and the republican
party will realize whoa
we are in real rough shape trump lost
the house for us in 2018.
trump lost the senate for us in 2020.
trump lost the white house for us in
2020 we have nothing
so we have to unite we can't have a
republican civil war where right-wing
media and elected officials are on
opposing sides
and even within the republican party
there could be a civil war between
people like mitt romney
uh and people like lauren bobo bobert or
marjorie taylor green right so there's a
number of different civil wars that
that could take place the alternative is
that
there is a republican civil war where
one side of the republican party
accuses the other of not having stood
behind trump enough
of being willing to compromise with joe
biden whatever uh and that
we see a a civil war develop sean
hannity
earlier this week signaled that he is at
least willing to foment this civil war
uh apparently turning on mitch mcconnell
and
threatening the he at the time he was
the senate majority leader
now he's the senate minority leader
thanks to democrats taking control of
the senate
take a listen to this mitch i will give
you an a-plus on getting
constitutionalist judges on the bench
been great on judges
but frankly it looks like it's time now
if you're going to go along
with all of this nonsense we need new
leadership in the u.s senate
you can represent the people of kentucky
you're showing basically right now that
you're the king
of the establishment republicans that
frankly
have always had and remain having
contempt
for president trump but more importantly
the 75 million americans that voted for
him
americans want somebody that will fight
for their values and principles
not scheme behind closed doors with your
buddy chuckie schumer
very republican in the senate so much
like with maria bartoromo
sean hannity's direct line to the
president ended yesterday with the
inauguration of joe biden
he knows biden's not going to take his
calls like trump did
so hannity wants to stay relevant in
some way
and what's going on here is that hannity
believes he's still the decision maker
and the influence peddler now
he may be he may find a way to maintain
that role even though he doesn't
uh speak to to the president anymore it
would be really great for the left
to have a battle between right-wing
media and republicans
uh that that is only good for the left
and it's just what joe biden needs to
get going with some momentum republicans
so busy with infighting
that they are unable to uh obstruct
the things that joe biden wants to do to
clean up trump's mess
and um one other funny thing you know by
hannity talks about maybe we need new
leadership in the senate
there is new leadership in the senate
because democrats won the senate and
hannity of course means new republican
leadership
uh but the the new senate leadership is
democrats all together and this is going
to be very very interesting now
for people saying that uh i'm somehow
being hypocritical on this
i'm not i have said before a divided
democratic party with infighting
is bad for democrats and a divided
republican party
is bad for republicans the difference is
i want the republican party to be
divided because it will be bad for them
i didn't want the democratic party to be
divided
because it was going to be bad for the
left-wing movement and so i'm consistent
infighting is bad i just am going to
benefit
from republican infighting and thus i'm
fine with them doing that
send me your thoughts and we'll continue
to monitor this over the next few days
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video